camera and i uh together actually in
coalition government legislated for the
circumstances in which a referendum will
take place so you're happy with that
well i'll come to i am happy with that
he appears to change his mind i i think
it is perfectly sensible to say to you
in law that in future if your powers if
the sovereignty of our nation is anyway
shared or pooled with the european union
at that point it should be your choice
whether we carry on in the european
union or not it shouldn't be the choice
of the parliament or the government of
the day we shouldn't be able to instead
give your powers away behind your back
that is what we legislated for in 2011
and there are stirring speeches by
william hague and david cameron in the
house of commons saying this is the
right approach within months the ink was
barely dry on the on the legislation the
conservatives have now changed their
mind again and again and again and again
but i remain of the view as i always
have done is that we should have a
referendum on whether we should stay in
or leave the european union when when
new powers are given up to the european
union and i will by the way again shock
horror always argue that we remain part
of the european union flawed though it
is because i think if we quit we become
poorer unemployment goes up and
investments